the un's peacekeeping mission in the
Democratic Republic of Congo known as
monusco is one of the largest and
longest running in the world despite
that the situation in the east of the
country continues to deteriorate in the
last 18 months the peacekeepers and
their bases have themselves come under
attack and civilians have been killed by
a number of different armed groups
last week when the president of DRC
Felix chisakady addressed the UN General
Assembly he accused one of those groups
known as M23 and being a proxy force of
his country's neighbor Rwanda
he's also demanding that the UN
accelerate its withdrawal from the
country and he said that should now
start after elections which take place
in December
this timeline is challenging for the UN
and its special representative in DRC
who's been briefing the U.N security
Council the government now wants you to
speed up the plans for the withdrawal of
your mission
do you think that is wise given the
situation on the ground is only getting
worse oh the government has made a
decision the decision has been
communicated to the security Council
it's now up to the security Council in a
dialogue with the government of DRC to
decide what is the best way
one of the main problems the UN now
faces is the fact they're no longer
welcomed by the majority of people in
eastern DRC deception characteristics it
was a useless Mission which originally
raised hopes about regaining peace and
Security in our region but unfortunately
what we witnessed was more crime under
manusco than before menusco
after 25 years I don't believe this
Mission lived up to its responsibility
for our population because nothing has
changed on the ground
U.N peacekeepers have been stationed in
the Democratic Republic of Congo for
almost a quarter of a century I'm told
now there's an acknowledgment even at
the highest levels of the United Nations
that the status quo cannot continue but
the withdrawal of the peacekeepers would
be difficult and could lead to an even
more dangerous situation on the ground
James Bay's Al Jazeera of the United
Nations
thousands of migrants are continuing
their Journey from Mexico
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera